during today's briefing our participants
are physically distant and in
separate rooms we've removed our masks
so you can hear us clearly during the
conference
our panel today consists of kenny todd
deputy manager of the international
space station program
rec henfling january 27th spacewalk
flight director
sarah corona january 27 spacewalk
officer
vincent lacourt february 1st spacewalk
flight director and sandy fletcher
february 1st spacewalk officer
we'll let our briefers provide us with
today's spacewalk information and accept
questions after
for members of the media if you'd like
to ask a question please press
star 1 for your name to be entered into
the queue to withdraw your question
press star 2 and please direct your
question to a specific panelist
if you're watching online you can tweet
a question with the hashtag
asknasa thanks again for joining us
today and with that we'll get started
with some opening remarks from kenny
todd
well thank you leah and uh good
afternoon uh to everyone out there um
and happy new year i hope everybody is
is doing well
um while uh a lot of us down on the
ground here were
celebrating uh the holiday season
expedition 64 on orbit was uh was doing
a fantastic job
turning turning a couple of cargo
vehicles um spacex 21 and also our north
gunman
grumman cygnus module um were on board
over the holiday period and the crew did
a fantastic job at moving a a lot of
cargo
doing a lot of science and uh when we
turned into the new year
uh over the first and second weeks we
closed out those modules and
and uh we sent the the northrop grumman
uh module away full of trash
which uh oftentimes is a is a is a
a big problem for us we have to be
concerned with and so so it's always
good to see
uh one of those modules leave and and
taking a lot of stuff on
away from station that we really don't
need anymore and then
on the flip side of that spacex 21 had a
beautiful splash down um in the in the
second week of january
returning a whole lot of really precious
and and
important cargo for a lot of a lot of uh
scientists and investigators here on
on earth so we were excited to get those
uh two two missions in our rear view
mirror
and uh basically close out the first
half of expedition 64.
so now now we're starting the the second
half of this expedition
and and we're going to turn the corner
and and and do some ebas and so we're
we're excited um we've been talking
about this particular set of evas these
two ebas for the better part of a year
so
i'm certainly ready to to uh to be done
talking about them and actually go
go see them executed and i'm sure all of
my my fellow panel members are as well
so
uh we're excited to get on with that um
once we uh
once we get past these two ebas we'll
turn our
attention uh towards the arrival of the
next northrop grumman cygnus module
um right now the launch is planned for
the 20th of february
uh it'll it'll arrive at station a
couple of days later
and again bringing about about 3 600
kilograms of cargo
with it so again uh there's a lot of
cargo a lot of a lot of research coming
to station these days so we're uh
we're really excited about that um once
we
once we get ng 15 what's what we refer
to it as ng-15 once we get it on the
international space station
uh we're thinking about trying to go
back and and get the other two evas
i think i've mentioned in several of
these briefings that we've been tracking
about four evas that we would like to
get done during this increment so
we'll see if we can go through those
last two ebas in around the end of
february early march time frame
but we also know that around the
mid-march time frame will really
start to to ramp up our our preparations
uh for doing some visiting vehicle
operations uh for our crude vehicles uh
the soyuz
uh needs to do a relocation and then uh
shortly after that the new soyuz will be
arriving with
with the with the new crew and uh and
then uh shortly after that we'll
we'll be uh turning our attention to
doing a uh
um a return of the crew one crew and
then the
onboarding of the crew ii uh spacex
dragon so
anyway so there's a lot going on uh
right now we're really excited to again
right in front of us here at the start
of the second half of the increment
uh really getting these evas going um
this first one
again a lot of it focused on on our
international partners specifically
the european space agency and their
columbus module uh
putting a communication antenna out as
well as as well as uh
completing some outfitting on their
bartolomyo payload um
or a structure that's on the outside of
their module
for housing payloads so uh rick and rick
and his team will tell you
about the specifics of that but we're
excited to to finally get those
activities done for for one of our
partners and and um
in between these first and second evas
we're going to do uh another task that a
lot of us have been waiting on
for a while as many of you might know
we've we've been
replacing the batteries on the outside
of station on our solar rays for a
number of years
and we completed the last set here
late last year but there was one battery
that
that failed on us shortly after we
installed it a little over a year ago
and so we now have the spare on board
for that particular
location battery location and so we'll
go swap that out
uh shortly after this first eba and then
and then
the second eba the team there will go in
and clean up that work site and make
sure that we're good for the
for the long term and again they can
they can talk to you about the details
of
of all the things they're doing but
again very excited to be here i'm glad
to finally get to
get these evas on the schedule and and
we're ready to go
and with that i'll hand it over to rick
okay thanks kenny
my name is rick henfling i'm the lead
flight director for the spacewalk that
will be on january 27th
it's named the columbus upgrades eva
first and foremost i wanted to extend my
thanks to healthcare workers around the
world for their tireless efforts
as we've endured through this pandemic
it's a it's a tremendous privilege to be
the lead flight director
for this upcoming spacewalk we've got a
really strong international team
involving our european colleagues we
have been preparing for the better part
of a year
as we awaited the arrival of the bartala
mail platform
it arrived on the spacex crs-20 mission
last april it was installed robotically
and now we have a few more tasks
using our walkers to hook up the power
and data connections
um we uh we've got a really strong team
uh we've uh
trained together both our european team
and our team here in houston
and we're ready to go next wednesday as
far as crew preparations today the crew
members
performed some standard maintenance on
their spacesuits to ensure the cooling
loops were configured properly for
next week's space spacewalk and
in the afternoon today they shifted
their efforts towards a procedure review
and study time
and uh just a few minutes ago we conf we
finished our final conference
uh with the crew members uh answering
any questions they may have
uh leading up to the eva tomorrow is
going to be an off duty day for
uh the the crew members and then on
sunday
we'll have mike hopkins and victor
glover get into their spacesuits
for what we call as an on-orbit fit
check verification
as you may be aware when uh when
astronauts get into zero g their their
bodies tend to grow they get a little
bit taller
and so we're going to get into the
spacesuits on sunday and make sure that
everything still fits perfectly so that
the crew members are comfortable when
they go out and perform their spacewalk
when we get into monday and tuesday next
week we'll finish our preparations we'll
have
another conference with the crew members
and then all leading up to
the spacewalk on wednesday which will
begin approximately
six o'clock am central time
with that i will hand over to sarah
corona who is our lead spacewalk officer
for next wednesday's eba
a pleasure to be part of this team and
we are very excited to
execute it i did want to call out the
folks in the back room who are going to
be helping out
for this eva and the next eva which is
mitch harger
colin murphy and reagan cheney and so
with that we have a video
to show the choreography of this eva so
we'll show the video and then we'll come
back and i've got some hardware to show
you
so
us eva coal upgrades is going to begin
with
ev1 egressing the quest airlock first
the crew is going to be bringing out
with them the kolka
which stands for the columbus ka band
antenna
this hardware is going to be installed
on the columbus module during this eba
ev1 is going to translate out to the
columbus module
via the translation path you can see
here
and we'll need to set up a few things at
the worksite before that installation
eb2 is going to translate to an external
platform
called esp2 where he is going to be
ingressing the ssrms the robotic arm
the robotic arm is going to be taking
him over to the columbus worksite
with the coca so the crew members are
going to meet up
at the worksite they need to remove
bolts
that are on the columbus panels
where those boats are removed is where
the cochlea is going to be installed
so they work together securing coca to
the columbus module
once it is secure pb2 is going to
route the cabling for that cochlea
and plug it into the columbus module
meanwhile
ev1 is going to head to the bartolomeo
platform
so bartolomeo is an external platform
in which payloads can be installed
there are clamps that need to be opened
up in order to remove the cabling
that needs to get rounded in order to
activate the barbell mail platform
so the crew works together to get those
cables routed and installed
ev1 also needs to remove another
aesthetic maybelline
that is going to hook up an antenna for
var de la mayo as you can see here
once bartolomeo is complete the crew
members are going to go
back to the polka and remove a cover
so the cover was installed in order to
protect the antenna
during installation since it's no longer
needed
we are going to have ev2 jettison
that cover while he's on the ssrms
[Music]
once the activities are complete at the
columbus worksite
both crew members meet back up at the
quest airlock
they reconfigure some bags
to take out with them for their next
task which is going to be
out at the fort most section of the
space station truss
they're going to be heading out to p6
you can see the translation path here
and the crew members are going to be
removing an h fixture
so this h fixture is not needed on
the solar arrays so we're going to
remove that h fixture
both of them are going to be removing
one of them
and this plate is going to be removed
because it's going to be
where a future upgrade of the
solar arrays is going to be installed
so the plates are removed put into a bag
and they will be brought back inside
after the eba so once both crew members
are complete with that
they both head back to the quest air
lock and we have completed
the plan tasks for the uda if there is
some time
at the end of the eba we will have some
get-aheads for the crew to perform
[Music]
okay so i was able to bring a maca of
the h fixtures
so this is a robotic interface that is
no longer needed
and this is the the last task that we
have for the eba
and we are heading out to the the
portmost
um part of the trust so out on p6 and so
each crew member is going to be removing
this h fixture
so it is secured by four bolts so
they're going to release those bolts
and then tie this pry this plate
um off structure so this is what's going
to be coming back inside station
and this is this is what's on the solar
array and these attach points
is what we're going to use to upgrade
the the
solar array system on future evas
okay and that's all i have for the
columbus upgrades
you can move on to vincent thanks sarah
so my name is vincent court i'm the lead
flight director for the iss upgrades 2
spacewalk as kenny mentioned we have one
new lithium-ion battery that we need to
get installed
so before the eva we need to do some
activities that we execute from the
ground
starting the night of the club
we start to discharge two of the old
style nickel
hydrogen batteries that takes us about
two days
after that is complete we do two days of
ground robotics activities
where we remove those two batteries and
install the new
lithium ion battery and at that point we
are ready
for our spacewalk our first task moves
an adapter plate
and that allows us to connect the
electrical connector
to that battery and then it is ready for
use
the other three major tasks for our
spacewalk are camera related tasks
we are replacing one of our degraded
cameras on the space station
and then we are upgrading and installing
one of our um
in one of the places where we only have
an sd standard dev camera
and installing a high definition camera
and then lastly we're going to the
japanese
robotic arm and replacing a camera and
light assembly there
at this point i'm going to hand off to
our lead spacecraft officer
sandy fletcher and she's going to
narrate an animation
to give you more details on our
spacewalk
thank you
to begin the iss upgrades to eva
ev1 with red stripes egresses the
airlock
followed by ev2
both crew translate to the 4 alpha
integrated equipment assembly
where ev1 installs a scoop on the direct
current switching unit
and ev2 stows a tool bag onto the
adapter plate
the crew work together to remove the
adapter plate from slot 2
and bring it to slot six
[Music]
to install the adapter plate the ev crew
drive two bolts on the adapter plate
[Music]
ev1 drives one bolt on the lithium-ion
battery
in slot 5. ev2
uses a ratchet wrench to break torque on
the direct current switching unit
and then resets the torque at a lower
value
with the pistol grip tool
ev2 connects the adapter plate to the
lithium ion battery
completing the circuit for the four
alpha three power channel
ev1 translates to the four alpha beta
gimbal assembly
ev1 removes the h fixture in preparation
for a future eva
ev1 then returns to the airlock
[Music]
ev2 previously returned to the airlock
and now goes to the external stowage
platform too
ev2 removes a portable foot restraint
installs it onto the robotic arm and
then ingresses
robotic arm takes eb2 to the camera port
3 worksite the s1 lower
outboard location ev1
brings out the replacement camera group
to the worksite
[Music]
with both crew at the worksite ev2
releases three bolts and removes the
failed camera group
the crew swap out the failed and
replacement units
then ev2 installs and drives three bolts
ev1 then returns the failed unit
to the airlock
the arm flies ev2 over to the us
laboratory module
and the camera port 13 worksite
ev2 installs an external high definition
camera
onto the current camera group
ev2 mates connections and installs a
strap
before returning to the external
platform too
since there are no further arm
operations during this
eva ev2 will egress the arm
and remove the portable foot restraint
[Music]
after ev1 stows the failed camera group
3
in the airlock he retrieves the new
wrist
vision equipment box and translates
along the us laboratory
in node 2 module then under the japanese
experiment module
to the exposed facility
[Music]
at the base of the japanese robotic arm
ev1 stows a tool bag carrying the wrist
vision equipment
this box provides a camera view and
light to support
arm operations
ev1 installs a scoop which is a handling
aid
onto the failed wrist vision equipment
box
and then removes the box
then installs the new wrist vision
equipment box
and removes the handling aid from that
and stows that in the tool bag
[Music]
ev1 retrieves the tool bag with the
failed wrist
vision equipment and then
retraces his path along
the japanese experiment module
the node 2 module to the us laboratory
one goal